the archetype of initiation in a
psychological sense the hero image is
not to be regarded as identical with the
ego proper it is better described as the
symbolic means by which the ego
separates itself from the archetypes
evoked by the parental images in early
childhood dr. young has suggested that
each human being has originally a
feeling of wholeness a powerful and
complete sense of the self and from the
self the totality of the psyche the
individualized ego consciousness emerges
as the individual grows up within the
past few years the works of certain
followers of Jung have begun to document
the series of events by which the
individual ego emerges during the
transition from infancy through
childhood this separation can never
become final without severe injury to
the original sense of wholeness and the
ego must continually return to
re-establish its relation to the self in
order to maintain a condition of psychic
health it would appear from my studies
that the hero myth is the first stage in
the differentiation of the psyche I have
suggested that it seems to go through a
fourfold cycle by which the ego seeks to
achieve its relative autonomy from the
original condition of wholeness unless
some degree of autonomy is achieved the
individual is unable to relate himself
to his adult environment but the hero
myth does not ensure that this
liberation will occur it only shows how
it is possible for it to occur so that
the ego may achieve consciousness there
remains the problem of maintaining and
developing that consciousness in a
meaningful way so that the individual
can live a useful life and can achieve
the necessary sense of self distinction
in society ancient history and the
rituals of contemporary primitive
societies have provided us with a wealth
of material about myths and rites of
initiation whereby young men and women
are weaned away from their parents and
forcibly made members of their clan or
tribe but in making this break with the
childhood world the original parent
a type will be injured and the damage
must be made goodbye a healing process
of assimilation into the life of the
group the identity of the group and the
individual is often symbolized by a
totem animal thus the group fulfills the
claims of the injured archetype and
becomes a kind of second parent to which
the young our first symbolically
sacrificed only to re-emerge into a new
life in this drastic ceremony which
looks very like a sacrifice to the
powers that might hold the young man
back as dr. young has put it we see how
the power of the original archetype can
never be permanently overcome in the
manner envisaged by the hero dragon
battle without a crippling sense of
alienation from the fruitful powers of
the unconscious we saw in the myth of
the twins how their hubris expressing
excessive ego self separation was
corrected by their own fear of the
consequences which forced them back into
a harmonious ego self relation in tribal
societies it is the initiation rite that
most effectively solves this problem the
ritual takes the novice back to the
deepest level of original mother-child
identity or ego self-identity thus
forcing him to experience a symbolic
death in other words his identity is
temporarily dismembered or dissolved in
the collective unconscious from this
state he is then ceremonially rescued by
the right of the new birth this is the
first act of true consolidation of the
ego with the larger group expressed as
totem clan or tribe or all three
combined the ritual whether it is found
in tribal groups or in more complex
societies invariably insists upon this
right of death and rebirth which
provides the novice with a rite of
passage from one stage of life to the
next whether it is from early childhood
to later childhood or from early to late
adolescence and from them to maturity
initiatory events are not of course
confined to the psychology of youth
every new phase of development
throughout an individual's life is
accompanied by a rapid
of the original conflict between the
claims of the self and the claims of the
ego
in fact this conflict may be expressed
more powerfully at the period of
transition from early maturity to middle
age between 35 and 40 in our society
than at any other time in life and the
transition from middle-aged to old age
creates again the need for affirmation
of the difference between the ego and
the total psyche the hero receives his
last call to action in defense of ego
consciousness against the approaching
dissolution of life in death at these
crucial periods the archetype of
initiation is strongly activated to
provide a meaningful transition that
offer is something more spiritually
satisfying than the adolescent rights
with their strong secular flavor the
archetypal patterns of initiation in
this religious sense known since ancient
times as the mysteries are woven into
the texture of all ecclesiastical
rituals requiring a special manner of
worship at the time of birth marriage or
death as in our study of the hero myth
so in the study of initiation we must
look for examples in the subjective
experiences of modern people and
especially of those who have undergone
analysis it is not surprising that there
should appear in the unconscious of
someone who is seeking help from a
doctor specializing in psychic disorders
images that duplicate the major patterns
of initiation as we know them from
history perhaps the colonists of these
themes to be found in young people is
the ordeal or a trial of strength
this might seem to be identical with
what we have already noticed in modern
dreams illustrating the hero myth such
as the sailor who had to submit to the
weather and to beatings or that proof of
fitness represented in the hike through
India of the man without a rain hat we
can also see this theme of physical
suffering carried to its logical end in
the first dream I discussed when the
handsome young man became a human
sacrifice on an altar this sacrifice
resembled the approach to initiation but
its end was obscured it seemed to round
off the hero cycle to make way for a new
theme there is one striking difference
between the hero myth and the initiation
right the typical hero figures exhaust
their efforts in achieving the goal of
their ambitions in short they become
successful even if immediately afterward
they are punished or killed for their
hubris in contrast to this the novice
for initiation is called upon to give up
willful ambition and all desire and to
submit to the ordeal he must be willing
to experience this trial without hope of
success in fact he must be prepared to
die and though the token of his ordeal
may be mild a period of fasting the
knocking out of a tooth or tattooing or
agonizing the infliction of the wounds
of circumcision sub incision or other
mutilations the purpose remains always
the same to create the symbolic mood of
death from which may spring the symbolic
mood of rebirth a young man of
twenty-five dreams of climbing a
mountain on top of which there is a kind
of altar near the altar he sees a
sarcophagus with a statue of himself
upon it then a veiled priest approaches
carrying a staff on which there glows a
living some disc discussing the dream
later the young man said that climbing a
mountain reminded him of the effort he
was making in his analysis to achieve
self mastery to his surprise he finds
himself as it were dead and instead of a
sense of achievement he feels
deprivation and fear then comes a
feeling of strength and rejuvenation as
he is bathed in the warm rays of the Sun
disc this dream shows quite succinctly
the distinction we must make between
initiation and the hero myth the act of
climbing the mountain seems to suggest a
trial of strength it is the will to
achieve ego consciousness in the heroic
phase of adolescent development the
patient had evidently thought that his
approach to therapy would be like his
approach to other tests of manhood which
he had approached in the competitive
manner characteristic of young men in
our society but the theme by the alter
corrected this mistaken assumption
showing him that his task is rather to
submit to a Power greater than himself
he must see himself as if he were dead
and in
in a symbolic form the sarcophagus that
recalls the archetypal mother as the
original container of all life only by
such an active submission can he
experience rebirth an invigorating
ritual brings him to life again as the
symbolic son of a son father here again
we might confuse this with a hero cycle
that of the twins the children of the
Sun but in this case we have no
indication that the initiate will
overreach himself instead he has learned
the lesson in humility by experiencing a
right of death and rebirth that marks
his passage from youth to maturity
according to his chronological age he
should already have made this transition
but a prolonged period of Arrested
Development has held him back this delay
had plunged him into a neurosis for
which he had come for treatment and the
dream offers him the same wise counsel
that he could have been given by any
good tribal medicine man that he should
give up scaling mountains to prove his
strength and submit to the meaningful
ritual of an initiatory chain that could
fit him for the new moral
responsibilities of manhood the theme of
submission as an essential attitude
toward promotion of the successful
initiation rite can be clearly seen in
the case of girls or women their rite of
passage initially emphasizes their
essential passivity and this is
reinforced by the psychological
limitation on their autonomy imposed by
the menstrual cycle it has been
suggested that the menstrual cycle may
actually be the major part of initiation
from a woman's point of view since it
has the power to awaken the deepest
sense of obedience to life's creative
power over her thus she willingly gives
herself to her womanly function much as
a man gives himself to his assigned role
in the community life of his group on
the other hand the woman no less than
the man has her initial trials of
strength that lead to a final sacrifice
for the sake of experiencing the new
birth this sacrifice enables a woman to
free herself from the entanglement of
personal relation
and fit sir for a more conscious role as
an individual in her own right
in contrast a man's sacrifice is a
surrender of his sacred independence he
becomes more consciously related to
woman here we come to that aspect of
initiation which acquaints man with
woman and woman with man in such a way
is to correct some sort of original
male/female opposition man's knowledge
logos then encounters woman's
relatedness eros and their union is
represented as that symbolic ritual of a
sacred marriage which has been at the
heart of initiation since its origins in
the mystery religions of antiquity but
this is exceedingly difficult for modern
people to grasp and it frequently takes
a special crisis in their lives to make
them understand it several patients have
told me dreams in which the motif of
sacrifice is combined with the motif of
the sacred marriage one of these was
produced by a young man who had fallen
in love but was unwilling to marry for
fear that marriage would become a kind
of prison presided over by a powerful
mother figure his own mother had been a
strong influence in his childhood and
his future mother-in-law presented a
similar threat would not his wife-to-be
dominate him in the same way these
mothers had dominated their children in
his dream he was engaged in a ritual
dance along with another man and two
other women one of whom was his fiancee
the others were an older man and wife
who impressed the dreamer because
despite their closeness to each other
they seemed to have room for their
individual differences and did not
appear to be possessive these two
therefore represented to this young man
a married state that did not impose
undue constraint on the development of
the individual nature of the two
partners if it were possible for him to
achieve this condition marriage would
then become acceptable to him in the
ritual dance each man faced his woman
partner and all four took their places
at the corners of a square dancing
ground as they danced it became apparent
that this was also a kind of sword dance
each dancer had in his hand a short
sword with which to perform a difficult
arabesque
moving arms and legs in a series of
movements that suggested alternate in
pulses of aggression and submission to
each other in the final scene of the
dance all four dancers had to plunge the
swords into their own breasts and die
only the dreamer refused to accomplish
the final suicide and was left standing
alone after the others had fallen he
felt deeply ashamed of his cowardly
failure to sacrifice himself with the
others this dream brought home to my
patient the fact that he was more than
ready to change his attitude to life he
had been self-centered seeking the
illusory safety of personal independence
but inwardly dominated by the fears
caused by childhood subjection to his
mother he needed a challenge to his
manhood in order to see that unless he
sacrificed his childish state of mind he
would be left isolated than the shamed
the dream and his subsequent insight
into its meaning dispelled his doubts he
had passed through the symbolic right by
which a young man gives up his exclusive
autonomy and accepts his shared life in
a related not just heroic form and so he
married and found appropriate fulfilment
in his relationship with his wife far
from impairing his effectiveness in the
world
his marriage actually enhanced it quite
apart from the neurotic fear that
invisible mother's or Father's may be
lurking behind the marriage veil even
the normal young man has good reason to
feel apprehensive about the wedding
ritual it is essentially a woman's
initiation rite in which a man is bound
to feel like anything but a conquering
hero no wonder we find in tribal
societies such counter phobic rituals as
the abduction or rape of the bride it
enabled the man to cling to the remnants
of his heroic role at the very moment
that he must submit to his bride and
assume the responsibilities of marriage
but the theme of marriage is an image of
such universality that it also has a
deeper meaning it is an acceptable even
necessary symbolic discovery of the
feminine component of a man's own psyche
just as much as it is the acquisition of
a real wife so
may encounter this archetype in a man of
any age in response to a suitable
stimulus not all women however react
trustingly to the married state a woman
patient who had unfulfilled longings for
a career which she had had to give up
for a very difficult and short-lived
marriage dreamed that she was kneeling
opposite a man who was also kneeling he
had a ring that he prepared to put on
her fingers but she stretched out her
right hand ring finger in a tense manner
evidently resisting this ritual of
marital Union it was easy to point out
her significant error instead of
offering the left-hand ring finger by
which she could accept a balanced and
natural relation to the masculine
principle
she had wrongly assumed that she had to
put her entire conscious that is right
sided identity in the service of the man
in fact marriage required her to share
with him only that subliminal natural
that is left-handed part of herself in
which the principle of Union would have
a symbolic not a literal or absolute
meaning her fear was the fear of the
woman who dreads to lose her identity in
a strongly patriarchal marriage which
this woman had good reason to resist
nevertheless the sacred marriage as an
archetypal form has a particularly
important meaning for the psychology of
women and one for which they are
prepared during their adolescence by
many preliminary events of an initiatory
character